foreign
Depp getting quite the welcome home
kissing hugging and loving on girlfriend
07 oh Shake I've been just connecting to
those feelings was was key for me the
romantic moment playing out at LAX on
Thursday Lily arriving back in Los
Angeles from a whirlwind press tour for
her new show the idol in can y'all got a
big
big Premiere at can
so how is that a five-minute Standing
Ovation it was incredible like it felt
like you know it felt like such a
beautiful celebration and like
culmination of of everything that we've
you know everything that we've been
through together and and just like to
kind of uh yeah the beautiful process
that was making the show and and
creating this little family together and
it just felt really really nice and
special to get to celebrate together and
we're just so
um happy with the response from from the
room
The Love Fest comes just a month after
Lily Rose hard launched the relationship
on IG posting this puckered up pic on
her story writing four months with my
crush 070 Shake real name Danielle
balbuena first sparked romance rumors
with Johnny Depp's daughter at Paris
fashion week in February but that snap
was the first time they officially
confirmed they were an item I feel very
very lucky to be able to do that Lily's
life seems to be all about love these
days on and off screen the idol centers
on her pop star character Jocelyn
falling for a cult leader played by the
weekend Jenny you were actually you were
literally a K-pop Idol so did you give
Lily any advice when it came to
performing as Jocelyn I do remember we
did have this conversation like long
time ago obviously like I'm not a pop
star I don't know anything about this
world and everything so you know any
kind of insight into just like kind of
you know just what it's like to be in
those shoes and everything is always
helpful and you know who best to learn
from but these two enable the
buzzedabout show doesn't Premiere until
June 4th on HBO but has already made
major headlines for its graphic and
controversial scenes
why don't you just be yourself
because there's nothing about me that's
relatable we actually Drew from a lot of
other influences that are not pop stars
like you know we thought a lot about
um uh Sharon Stone in Basic Instinct and
like all of these other women that were
very
um uh that were very inspiring to me for
for the role the series follows Jocelyn
as she attempts to rebuild her music
career after a nervous breakdown
that's sex this is sex that sucks that's
what we're selling well but IRL it seems
Lily Rose is living the dream
laughs